what are we doing right now like what am
I going what am i doing you're on this
for Daymond John's book what am i doing
you're talking with him he fires
archenemy yep great natural way I'm mom
doesn't got a chronic rabbit I come
around like a visible Adachi with
clarity hustle my my name is Gary Thomas
I've been telling you
accountants of equity I'll triple they
given a pedigree Devine and our pleasure
my fantasy putting the work that I'm
doing are the moving furniture seven by
the way everything I do is always
intended to figure out who the winner
who's a loser
[Music]
what's about binary how you react to
something is a telltale sign of your
feelings internally ty scale that's how
you really scale with you that's how
used to do you do things that expose
people how people react to things who
they are what's cooking I'm glad and
like Mick you win for what I can control
you've got your part to control because
of the way I've managed I know a lot
more about you
I need those white spaces for you to be
you strengths weaknesses curiosities
growth historical context
so when we do things it's also an
insight on people use people new people
for literally a plus players crushing it
every see fact they've gotten is
phenomenal we have a restructure and
they're crying and texting or they can
lose their job that's important for me
to know that oh my god that person's
massively in right you're right so I can
help them yeah you see where I'm going
but if I'd circumvented the front in one
Sally you're fine I will never know
communism capitalism you got it
macro management not micro yeah I'm
doing it cuz I want to help yeah okay
cool I when I got good that would I get
some extent
you know how much that helps me now we
can help that person because you want
them to be here cool I love spending
time with you hmm
I was like oh he s just got a little
cute let's go let's go think yeah I like
my channel very good
sup Sammy hey how are you good how are
you miss welcome it allows them to skip
their death
actually you know what Sam everything
hey guys do it welcome I'll see you soon
is this your whole like now that I'm
doing this thing I'm just not going to
cut any hair off anywhere you're a man
you're a you're a man
no you're a man you're just a man you're
just a man yeah more more MORE
hello hey bud hey bud you're going to
impart some wisdom on a sales person to
try and get them to get a straight
answer from some type of prospect what
would you say to them because it is so
hard and you're not the other person but
what do you need to do for them to come
back and say I'm a little bit different
on this one my jokes well let's find out
yeah my answer is don't chase them and
you've on to the next one I do not sell
the unsellable if you don't return my
email and if you're dodging me and if
you're coming up with Jesus three
minutes before the call I have no
interest in chasing you how long do you
not a whole lot my I'm a Salesman so my
into it well right I go back go back a
year I'm going back to being a 13 year
old selling bass book I'm telling you
the truth this is why I told you I was
going to be different but I also I also
think that I'm as good of a Salesman as
the most attractive girl on earth what I
mean by that is the most attractive girl
unearths advice to picking up guys is
going to look different than the than
the average pillar right like she's not
working it it's coming to her right I
think I've always sold stuff I believe
in I've
we've been great at selling and so for
me I just have no interest in chasing
you so and so so what I'm getting at is
the following
first of all salespeople and boy is this
the best piece of advice I can give the
amount of people that are in sales that
sell [ __ ] that they don't believe in is
extraordinary let me say it 15 more
times the amount of sales people that
sell stuff they don't believe in is
extraordinary which means you've already
lost I will say the one thing that
non-winning salespeople do the 85% of
the market who are successful yeah
but eventually won't be or will play
themselves out or tap out is they say no
for the other guy and girl oh they're
not going to you know about yeah if
you're a Salesman that says no yeah
you've lost yet I love you guys welcome
you are you good if I can you put a
challenger for me that passion is about
that survey oh no my aunt said my only
two service forces always been like I
never want to get pigeonholed because be
I don't know for now I'm going to do a
different ways because being a female
and it's like oh I have female etcetera
all right you're a minority woman you're
going to be pigeonholed your whole life
like people get pigeonholed like yo
original I'm break down the last week of
your oh [ __ ] but I get pigeonholed write
the first articles about vaynermedia was
wine boy wants to start agency people
get pigeonholed like you know the best
way not the new virgin hold execute yeah
punch him in the [ __ ] mouth right
like like we're all pigeon-holed whether
you know no matter what where you come
from or what everybody's picking do you
know the level disrespect to have for
white rich kid on the Upper East Side I
don't think he white rich boy I don't
think he has fire I pigeonhole him that
he's been given everything and he
champion so so like everybody's
pigeon-holed
so instead of like everybody debating
everybody being pigeon-holed and they're
their one struggle the whole game is
what you've done you've executed I knew
this is for Allah
yeah I think we all have too much heat
like when people see me oh sorry I
didn't know who you were like if I'm in
a good setting like South by where I I'm
always like I know like 99% of people
don't know who I am do you know what I
mean so I think like like the other
thing with pigeonholing is like I tell
my people up I'm like nobody goes
getting the best of you like nobody
really gives a [ __ ] sure very sure right
right so like I'm not worried about that
to me it's the reverse to me it's like
shift up the game you love because
there's something to be done there ok
let me know yeah well alright good to
see it yeah of course I was intrigued to
do it I wanted you so efficient with
time now it matters we're going to be
money because money the other thing the
other thing the other thing you're
feeling here is I want to get a deal
done yeah let's just get right to it and
if we can't great we could like without
a law we a long journey we could do in
16 years but I think a lot of people
just take meanings pandered it like
they're they take up time because
they're not trying to get anything done
I'm trying to get things done
[Music]
look at that good-looking man not only
is he very good-looking but he's one of
the great athletes of Eric's brother
good to see it where we live no this
will be on dailyvee not live how you
doing it's good to see him how the shoe
propria
good you did a bunch of everybody saying
you were really hustling look of course
he have fun superstar off the field so
you guys talk about the website right
now so you will have thousands more
people going to your gyms if you just
listen to me
yeah that's a message dealers like it is
you get the wrong strategy today smells
of work you know get a foul roof always
here and 300 is it too much work one I
get it so like let me tell you what to
do that will bring you the most value
the old caution is always from new
mother lode that's right
great there's new ways they cover you
you adjusted over when I could be over
when at the light going on listen
especially when the [ __ ] other
Brandon Marshall does shinu got to deal
with it I pay attention I understand
life I'm just telling you that you know
you're gonna regret if we don't do this
when you had me to do it when if you're
going to leave tens of millions of
dollars on a table you're comfortable
you're supposed to need to figure out of
data hang out I'll bring somebody
probably mate because he's on my team
and you can scale all the projects will
tell you exactly what to do will hang
out for 3-4 hours will literally make
sure everything's on point on your phone
will all talk together will create a
program that is feasible not something
you don't like only want to do is really
talk to and understand what you do and
don't want to do and then reverse
engineer that I'm not going to make
thinking [ __ ] you don't want to do but
I'm going to tell you and explain to you
what you should do
you're going to pick from the menu of
those things and it will change your
game it's where all the economics are
come with me I'll share my office
mommy what you don't get to come in the
Geist of a Bears fan hi I love alright
get my hug your Realtor I don't know
he's a grown man I mean you know that's
of course do you see him I'll be in a
one sec I'll go in here actually you
know don't film this that's right so I
want you guys to do the following this
is gonna [ __ ] work
alright iPhone I want you to record
and [ __ ]
for everything because their improv but
there's 50 of them now here so I don't
gain vicunas get me to improv kids in
this office I want to be I want you to
literally stillness I want you to
literally film like them either in the
office or go film I'm at a bar if you
got a second on the phone because I want
to show this to them it's going to be
like you know basically the skit is like
hey I'll take them and the other
person's like wouldn't I want this slide
what is it 2009 and I want the person to
punch person and then I want you to
impose the logos on their faces guys I
think it's going to be a homerun me I
think this the reason I'm so fired up
and it's like oh like this could be this
could be the meaning that changes the
course of our agency I think they're
going to make us do it I I know what
they do what I want them to do at work
I don't debate it yeah it's a hundred it
just can't get it like
is an aggressive corporate America
campaign it will work
yeah all right good more cool yep you
guys take the take the rest okay okay
okay
and yep okay 421 Chad okay
so Jeff how are you man good to see you
sure I'm in the car
Belarus Club baby to do something
without Daymond John from shark tank
oh no just wanna say hi things are good
how are you
anything interesting
[Music]
that's a smart esophagus travel pull out
you're welcome what you mean or in
single mother how are you okay
Sandra Gary makes me too no worries it's
refreshing
thank you welcome in alright you look at
aid thank you only hold it you have any
people you inspire them more than you
think I know no sign you and you pat
yourself on the back of that yeah I'm
really comfortable I'm real guy my
number one fan not on a serious note
like it's the best feeling
yeah you should be feel awesome because
they do it although myself I have a five
year old and I'm running my own company
and I listen to you every morning thank
you so much means a lot inspiring thank
you thank you yeah it's awesome face
yeah yeah but I'd like to hear from like
forces absolute would happen when we
moved into this building last January
how about patio right here will have
she's insane that's incredible
typically she could be them first people
there right there once where I got me a
flat paper ha god I Love New York
I just love me or I just like love New
York more than every other city combined
it's a cool area - this is the fashion
district and all these people they're
all working trying to make it happen
cities New York is you never ever ever
go wrong my man what are you trying to
like steal all the outdoor space in New
York Sam and I appreciate you man really
I really appreciate it no worries so
simple had my people call your people
make sure to tap that's the way it's
done that's how we do it
rabbi I know I know how oh you know it's
all right ma'am I'm thrilled to do it
how you doing great this is incredible
it's great we have a good time here the
outdoor stuff is just incredible family
there is really good man been in it a
lot really
[Music]
I'm going to look at it one name like
what sounds more more MORE because I
bought it for three days look who's here
good agency welcome we don't have the
crew here you guys I love it
clearly tell me where you want me to
roll in I'll crush the [ __ ] out of it
for you I'm going to micromanage the
whole thing to bring it the most success
so I just want to have a clear tomorrow
what I want to get out of it whether
it's a dollar or whether it's and you
know me like I'm like this is all family
all of us so like I don't want you I
don't want you to worry for even 30
seconds about what my allocation is
because I want you to be successful it's
way more important for me of that then
whether I get two hundred five hundred
or 74 million I'm about to take stage
with Daymond John for this fireside chat
but when I get off I will I'll call you
brother had a humble bragging
thank you for being your book anyway to
give it up the BRB
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] off I hear one now thank you Emmy
great thank you I still want to talk
about fancy Oh can we stay another
minute of news can we stand I'm not I'm
not fulfilled yet we're fancy we have to
we have to have this conversation in
this space like we've got it
every entrepreneur in here has it's so
much better it's called the Internet at
scale so many things are easier than
what we came up with right you can DM
the person and maybe get to them I just
I want you guys to win which is why I
talk about this like when the money
dries up when the economy gets tighter
all of this goes away and the majority
in this market right now is on you know
on on bubblegum and dreams are like
you've got to know how to make money
like you have to have a business your
product has to bring value like the
tried and true is the only thing that's
going to make you successful people
running around here trying to raise
money oh I can't get raised money
because I didn't go to that kind of
school or they don't I don't get I can't
raise money because I didn't come from
that kind of neighborhood don't raise
money make money doesn't take a hero to
give up a piece of their business make
it with the day job or not I think you
have to be practical and hungry like you
should not quit your job if you got
crazy compounding interest on your
student loans or you've got to pay your
mortgage but what you shouldn't do is
have that job talk [ __ ] that you're
going to build some big business one day
and then at 6 o'clock at night not work
like you need to go to sleep at 3 a.m.
like you need to back your [ __ ] mouth
up everybody's talking [ __ ] everybody's
talking [ __ ] everybody's talking [ __ ]
everybody loves to hit me up Gary be
hustling I look at their account they're
like playing ping pong at 4:30 when
people understand what hustle is I took
one vacation in my 20s but I have crazy
aspiration you should take 11 but don't
come telling me you're going to buy the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers and so like the
first thing is figure out who you are
and what you want and then deploy real
self awareness but I'm telling you the
thing that I'm feel for loving a reason
I didn't step off stage yet is it's been
so good for almost a decade this has
been easy there's so much money out
there everybody's getting money for
their dumb ideas that they feel money
and if you're not that you should really
even question that
like if you haven't been able to raise
money you really [ __ ] suck because
the market is ridiculously ridiculous
like terrible like people getting funded
for everything so if you haven't been
able to figure out how to get money
you're a triple loser so the way to
answer that and punch me in the face and
tell me that you're not is going to make
me instead of dwelling why you haven't
raised it little more time okay
wrestlers will fight through the
admission now let me see you put your
head here cuz I wanted by man yeah
what's up I think that this confused me
was when you said if you're looking for
money you're a loser
yeah we're going to learn some people
have to love the money because I get a
less successful I got it so we can't
think of any further without wanted what
I said let's break it down what I said
was in detail was a lot of people
startups are going to fail here because
they're starting the business just for
more money right no no that's actually
not what I said
because I still believe in that too I
said the reason their business is going
to fail is because they're building it
yeah that's different right that's what
I actually don't look and that's
different because what does the love it
and it's not only that's right they
don't love it so they're looking that's
why everybody hits me up and says should
I go into the marijuana business they're
looking for trends should I go into Cael
there seemed friends and like oh that's
where the money is going to be and so
they go there and and the problem is if
you're not doing something you like you
can't work hard enough to actually
succeed it's too hard instead of what's
being said some of my employees don't
give a damn you can't expect the person
why would they feel the problem how do
you one person I've seen do that real
good is poppy cat so puppy has found a
way to get his employment
[ __ ] your ass but maybe it's also G well
I don't know pop well enough to know but
the real way to do it and it's really
worked for me as well is I keep talking
to these guys and figuring out what I
spoke to Tyler I said I took something
from if kid when I show you a talent I
said okay tell me the truth if you want
to work here for a year
leverage that you work with me and go do
your old thing because I'll help you
we'll have a nice one year courtship
right there's a late day now right
you know like we'll have a great
one-year courtship and I'll put you on
War because if you tell me the truth
then I know what I'm dealing with right
so I think the way to get employees to
really really crush for you is do they
want money do they want work-life
balance do they want Fame what do they
want what's their version of success and
where we're really but this is where you
got to be real good and this takes a lot
of leadership you got to know what's
going to change everyday because when
they're 23 and coming into New York City
for the first time and they can work 18
hours a time but what happens when you
fall in love and you got to start a
family what happened like this like you
know if you trying to build a company
the way that I'm prohibited now based on
here I don't mean people who are sitting
again
I mean claiming so how long you go you
got to speak to them and you got to find
playmakers and then tell them what you
can bring to them and ask them what they
want from you you got to get up you got
to make them feel safe to tell you the
truth it's very real
you got to tell you got to get them to
feel safe to tell you the truth because
then you can play I'm sure your thing
coming up nor more reason I know hey
Sunline how are you bro what's the real
pleasure man real pleasure stay well to
me it's um what's really interesting is
in CPG land is there's so many variables
besides the marketing that's the reason
I've been able to build my company it's
just a macro game so is a macro game
you know yeah I mean it's also the
confines of that game right look you're
an unusual kind of character that's why
I'm allocating this time it's happy it's
because it's not it's not because I'm
doing anything other than reacting to
what you're doing
I'm just counter punching the reality of
the conversation I promise you something
about money money is real funny real
funny
money doesn't care what you look like
you may think it does I bet your [ __ ]
excuse
money wants to make some money it does
I'll give a Patriots fan money that's
how much I want to make money you
understand you can say anything you want
about you don't look the part white
woman black woman not from this country
money wants to make money so if you're
not getting it stuck so then go make it
instead of dwelling that the old white
guy and BC lands not giving me any money
it's because your [ __ ] sucks and so the
only way you can prove me wrong is to go
execute
[Music]
another day of grinding at midnight how
we do it
[Music]